cause you're telling women in general
because most girls aren't the exception
they're the rule and most fat chicks
aren't going to get the outcomes they
want that's so upsetting most people I'm
trying to find a way to make it sound
better than what you're saying but it's
hard yeah it's just true but it's like
for me I personally think I'm nicer to
women than most like men are because
most men will will no offense but Pander
not tell them the truth and and the
truth is when we speak we're talking
about the average chick most people are
average most girls are average looking
and an average looking girl if she's fat
she's below average yeah and now you're
thinking of the exception right of an
eight nine or ten and you know she she
when she gains weight she still is the
good shape she can she'll be fine but
most people are average